there's a humanitarian crisis unfolding
in southern mexico
for months waves of migrants and asylum
seekers mainly from haiti and central
america have poured into the city of
tapachula
migrants rights advocates say a national
policy by the mexican government aimed
at preventing migrants from making their
way north toward the united states has
turned the city into an open-air prison
for refugees
is a living hell
it is an illegal prison because nowhere
in the law does it say that migrants can
only be kept in one city
the streets have turned into
concentration centers
mexican immigration laws are being
perverted and manipulated in order to
appease the united states
the streets of tapachula are packed with
migrants this woman who has asked us to
conceal her identity is one of more than
35 000 haitian nationals currently stuck
in tapachula she says food and shelter
are in short supply and that the
situation here grows more dire by the
day
what we make in a day is not enough for
food and many of us migrants are
sleeping in the park on top of each
other begging for food if mexico's
president doesn't do something for us
people are going to begin to steal and
we don't want that what we want is help
and to allow us to keep moving
since the start of the year mexico's
national immigration strategy has been
one of containment in tapachula hundreds
of migrants queue up outside the city's
immigration offices almost every day
here confusion reigns and tensions are
on the rise the vast majority of people
we've encountered outside this
government office building say they're
growing desperate without a clear answer
from authorities as to what it's going
to take to obtain the necessary
paperwork and finally be allowed to
leave tapachula
despite promises from mexican political
leaders to respect the rights of
migrants and asylum seekers those who
try to leave tapachula without the
necessary paperwork are quickly rounded
up
and local journalists continue to
document cases of abuse and excessive
force from authorities we need to
recognize that these individuals that
are making this very risky journey are
in very difficult and vulnerable
situations uh as we've discussed there
are many women and children and children
who are actually in a company that means
they do not have a family member or a
guardian going with them sometimes
children who are very very young age and
so
what all governments need to do that are
involved in managing migration is that
they need to make sure that these human
rights are respected and that these very
vulnerable people are protected
migrant shelters in this part of the
country have reached maximum capacity
and some have experienced outbreaks of
covid19 coupled with a lack of access to
adequate healthcare growing security
concerns and a national policy that
prevents people from leaving the
situation is quickly growing beyond the
ability of authorities to control
manuel rapalo al jazeera tapachula
mexico